let's go to a caller from the 4-1-3
area code a very special area code
back in the original stomping grounds
of the david pakman show in western
massachusetts 4-1-3 who's this where are
you calling from
hello david i am a new viewer i've been
watching
probably for about uh six to eight
months now
okay my name is jordan jordan and where
are you calling from
i'm calling from western massachusetts
as he told a little town called ludlow
ludlow incredible and uh ludlow known
for
what is ludlow known for large
portuguese population
yes and uh our fantastic high school
soccer team yeah and the soccer team
that's exactly right all right
what's going on today and there's if you
can try to keep the phone just a little
further from your mouth just so you
don't come in so hot
yep you got it beautiful um so
my question is what do you think the
tipping point was for the sudden change
in um rhetoric from trump regarding
coronavirus
was the new campaign manager it
obviously wasn't the tulsa rally wasn't
the backlash for the fire
fauci uh retweets what do you think the
tipping point was
i think it's desperation i think at this
point so it's possible that removing
brad parscale as the manager and
bringing on that guy
bill stephen i think his name is it's
possible that stephen said
listen i will do it but you've got to
listen to me
and it what you're referring to for
people who didn't see it is earlier this
week when trump restarted the
coronavirus press briefings he did the
first one on tuesday
he came out and talked about how in
favor he is of masks trump said it may
get worse before it gets better rather
than constantly telling us that it's
about to go away
a very notable change in rhetoric i
think it's desperation i think at this
point trump sees the polling he publicly
says it's fake polling
i think he knows that it's real polling
and this is his last shot he's realizing
people start voting in six weeks um the
coronavirus is going to be here for some
time
um the vaccine is not going to be widely
available before the election
and he needs to try something else what
he's done so far hasn't worked i think
he's a desperate
cornered scared man the paramilitaries
in portland are part of it
try to create some confrontations to
make uh protesters look bad maybe
that'll help
a new rhetoric it's desperation and i
don't know whose idea it was but clearly
someone got to him and said you've got
to take a new approach
i would like to think that in a more
sane world
that the um scientific backlash and
especially from the cdc
gauche and redfield yes they're actually
sticking up for fauci
and that maybe just maybe he would have
listened to that but
obviously it has everything to do with
the re-election champion
everything that's happening right now is
about re-election and
trump's gambit was reopen reopen schools
reopen businesses reopen everything
hope that it doesn't get bad right away
so that things are okay enough in
october that people vote to re-elect
trump
clearly it's not happening clearly it's
not happening and the numbers have gone
the opposite direction so he's trying
the next thing and it is
all about getting reelected we'll see if
it works
yeah i guess like the the last example i
would
um offer up is do you think that there's
some internal
um charts or i'm sorry i'm forgetting
like the internal polling scientific
word
no not polling but um charts that are
showing
the projected death rate that is to come
in august
october september november oh
certainly and i mean listen some of
those are public and they're talking
about i think it's in the range of
you know reaching anywhere from two to
210 to 260 000 deaths if things continue
to accelerate and i'm sure that the
white house has all that data
yeah yeah well thank you for your time
david all right appreciate the phone
call thank you very much
great to hear from you